e
e e
are you
ready okay well I will open the regular
meeting of the legislative performance
audit and oversight committee and um
we've got a few things on the agenda
this morning the first is the acceptance
of the April meeting minutes move to
approve as written and presented second
so moved by Senator Lang seconded by
representative Griffin any changes
needed we don't need roll call for this
Voice vote okay Voice vote so all in
favor please say I I I any opposed
motion passes
unanimously okay Mr
Henry you're you guys are
on good morning Madam chair and uh
committee members for the record I'm
Christine Young director of audits for
the LBA and with me is Jay Henry
performance audit
supervisor and I'll just go ahead and
get started with an update of ongoing
and pending
audits the first one on the list is the
New Hampshire commission for human
rights the commission received a draft
copy of our report on April 9th we met
with the executive director in May uh to
discuss the report and answer any
questions after that meeting we received
additional information from the
commission uh resulting in changes to
the report we made the changes sent the
report um back to the Commission in
June a July 15th deadline was set for
the commission to send us audity
responses and unfortunately on that day
uh we were informed there was an
emergency and the commission's executive
director would not be returning to work
until the end of August at the
earliest so the the audit is currently
on pause until we receive audity
responses from the
commission moving on to special
education as you know the audit scope is
Broad and the subject matter is
complex the audit is currently staffed
with five Auditors we're more than
halfway through
fieldwork we're drafting observations
for completed portions of our work
five observations have already been sent
over to the department and another set
of observations is expected to be
drafted by late
September the report will be lengthy
with 50 plus
observations and a full draft report is
not expected until early
2025 at the
earliest moving on to education Freedom
accounts we've drafted the scope
statement you have that in your
materials uh Paige Loren performance
audit manager is available to present
the scope uh right now for your
consideration and approval if you would
like that I think we' like
that it's always great to see
Paige and we'll be looking for a vote on
this
good morning uh as Christine said I'm
paig Lauren the audit manager VA skids
is still the auditor in charge she just
couldn't make it to the meeting
today so on pages one through five the
scope statement is background
information on the EFA program starting
from with the
legislative uh the laws that put it into
effect we talk about the uh roster of
students who are
there um how the program was established
and what types of differentiated Aid
that the students may qualify for on
page two and there's four categories of
those uh these are the same categories
that uh public education students can
receive we discuss the EFA expenditures
that are allowed under the program on
pages two to three and this is the exact
law that is copied and pasted in
here we go on to discuss the scholarship
organization that has contracted with to
administer the
program the bullets below the that
paragraph discuss the payment system
that they have established as the
scholarship
organization on page four we discussed
the phase out grants those are entirely
handled by the Department of Education
and the scholarship organization does
not have any part in the phas out
grants bottom of page four we discuss
the Department's program oversight of
the educ education Freedom account
program we have background on the EFA
administrator position in there uh he is
majority he's mainly responsible for the
oversight of the program um the position
wasn't immediately established when the
EFA program went into effect so there's
a little bit of delay on the
Department's oversight of
EFA below that we discussed the audit
scope we lead in with the statutory
language that requires the audit
and our scope question would be how
effectively did nhed oversee the EFA
program during State fiscal years 2022
through
2024 we have a pretty detailed bolded
list of our objectives and some of the
methods we'll be using to fulfill those
objectives our audit period will be
State fiscal years 2022 through 2024
however we may have to look at a time
period outside of the audit period in
order to to understand relevant matters
within the audit period so it's not
completely limited to 2022 through
2024 as of today we expect to have a
final report to fiscal in the spring of
2025 we summarize the scope limitations
at the bottom of page
six the scope limitations have not
changed since our March 18th LPA
meeting uh there is a part of that first
paragraph is certain certain documents
that we will not be able to possess in
we will not able to obtain that are in
the possession of the scholarship
organization we have spoken to the
department and uh it will be up to their
discretion to request documents from the
scholarship
organization and the last paragraph is
the Department's position on the
authority to audit the scholarship
organization which was also discussed at
the March 18th
meeting and I can answer any questions
may have
from commit Senator Whit thank you madam
chair thanks for bringing this to us
today so it doesn't seem like there has
been any progress from uh you know sort
of our conversations from March 18th
about um you know what was required in
the law and um you know so the Doe's
hesitancy to assist the LBA is that
correct we are still working with them
on the documents they'll be able to
request on our behalf um it depend
depends on what we're looking at the
details as far as we can tell the
details of what we discussed at the
March 18th meeting are largely
unchanged so anything that the
department has done for its oversight we
won't be able to independently verify by
going to the scholarship organization to
obtain those similar materials or assess
the uh potential risks that we would
normally do in a regular audit we can
identify potential risks but in unless
we go into the scholarship organization
and obtain Source P documents we won't
be able to assess that full
risk um
so considering what the uh requirement
was in the law that required the audit
um sort of the Doe's sort of
unwillingness to um you know give access
or even request um access from the
scholarship organization to that primary
program data do you feel like the LBA is
sort of not able to comply with the law
uh because of that limitation we're
we're going to comply with the law in
the extent that we can once we publish a
report we do put scope limitations in
the report of the details of what
stopped us from going through the full
scope of what we usually audit in a
program so we will be able to fulfill
the statutory requirement I think we
just won't get as far as we do in our
normal audits follow up follow up so on
page six when you're talking and thank
you for identifying these limitations I
think that's really helpful for us on
page six um where you talk about the
scope limitations halfway through that
paragraph you uh say in the in the scope
uh limitations quote preliminary
discussions with NHD indicate most
documents pertaining to the EFA program
are solely in the possession of uh
CSF um and then uh give some examples
and then lastly that department of
education does not currently possess
documents associated with initial EFA
applications documents used for
determining eligibility for
differentiated Aid and annually
verifying residency or specific items
purchased by each student with the EFA
fund so can you expand on you know I
understand the Department's position
that um the audit can only uh look the
Auditors can only look at what the
Department of Education has it's clear
what they have and and what they do have
and what they don't have can you um
expand on sort of your conversation
about the Department's willingness
Department of education's willingness to
you know directly request what is
necessary to complete the audit sure so
what we'll do is we we're developing our
audit plan at this point and we are
going to go forward with our plan is if
we did have full access to the
documentation and as we progress with
that audit plan we still do not know
what exactly the department has versus
what the scholarship organization has so
we will still request all the
documentation you would need and then
we'll have to rely the department to let
us know what is unavailable and go
forward from there great and last
question has the Department of Education
indicated whether be they'd be willing
to request that information that you're
going to give you're going to request it
is going to be their discretion if it
directly impacts their oversight
responsibilities or something that we
identify in laws rules or the contract
that they should have they have stated
they're willing to reach out to the
scholarship Organization for those items
thank
you brother
questions yes representative Walmer so
recently there was a a compliance report
that came forth and um it was looking at
a very small number of students in the
um in the program I'm wondering how will
the lb's Auditors use that information
in this audit yeah we just received that
as well uh this past Friday so we
haven't gotten a chance to look over
everything we are reviewing it to
determine what we can work off to
independently verify information uh any
work papers that the department used
they've been willing that they've
retained from that they've been willing
to share those with us so we will get
access to those um as far as our audit
work it will not directly impact what we
have planned um because it's the
Department's work and they had access
directly so we won't be able to
independently verify what they did but
it is a good starting point in the types
of issues that they
identified one more question so I guess
I'm I'm trying will you do you
anticipate having any interviews or
conversations with the scholarship
organization it is our understanding
that we will not have access to the
scholarship organization
staff thank
you further
questions yes sen n thank you but to be
clear the Department of Education has
said they cooperate as you're reviewing
their oversight responsibility and how
they've implemented oversight over the
uh child scholarship fund and are
willing to provide any documentation to
show what policies procedures and rules
they have that have been put into place
including documentation where they've
executed oversight over that and
validated that oversight correct thank
you I have a question um so I think I
heard you say you just won't have access
to information to validate the
Department's responses so I'm trying to
think of the usual performance audits I
look at and there might be a I remember
one from lottery for example that said
they weren't locking the drawing room
door um it was some years ago
and so you would have had a way to
validate whether they were or were not
blocking the room where they drew the
the tickets but in
so you can look at their procedures and
policies for oversight but you won't be
able to
verify that they were getting the
information to comply with those
policies correct it appears that we
won't be able to verify their practice
conforms to their policies and
procedures so we'll take their word for
it we will report what the department
reports but that would be one of the
areas but we know it a goal
implementation that we were unable to
independently
verify so what kind
of
observations would you be able to
report to the legislature
I believe we'll be able like I said to
go through the requirements in state law
and we will be able to identify areas of
risk that the department should be
looking at we will not be able to assess
the extent of that risk that exists so
we can point out areas that the
department should be monitoring but
currently is not or there are no
controls or we have concerns about um we
will gather as much evidence as we can
to support those and uh just like I said
in Normal audit we would be able to do
some kind of sample at the source and
put numbers in place of how big that
risk is so if just I guess one more
question the audit gets to
respond the AUD being the department not
yes yeah they will respond to the uh
observations correct they have to
respond they I don't know anybody who
has not provided responses uh I believe
they have to have an opportunity to
respond they do not have to put
responses in the
report so we don't know if they'll
respond I we've had a few audits with
them so far and they've never not
responded so I'd be surprised if they
did not okay yeah
great Senor with me and then thank you
madam chair and and thank you for going
through this with us again it it does
feel like not much has changed since
March and at that meeting a number of
the members of this committee all of
whom are legislators you know this is a
bipartisan committee expressed concerns
that you know our job as elected
officials as legislators uh and more
specifically this committee's job is to
make sure that public dollars are being
used appropriately and in this case I
just want to clarify this is a situation
where Millions upon millions of public
dollars
are being put into a program operated by
a private
organization and due to the Department
of education's unwillingness to allow
the
legislative uh the legis you know the
LBA to go in and audit directly this
organization that is
utilizing and giving
out uh public dollars um you know do you
have concerns that you know we're being
uh our role as um you know the public
puts trust in us to make sure that
public dollars are being used
appropriately do you have any concerns
um based on the way that this has
proceeded that we're not going to be
able to to do that so far the we're
working with the department and doing
what we're statut required to do I think
after the report comes out or if the
oversight committee or the legislators
see their concerns that they may have
it's their authority to be able to put
something in place for that um I believe
we're did you speak into the sorry P
always afraid I'm too close to it um I
was just saying that after this we will
be able to fulfill the statutory
obligations that are given to us and we
will provide a report if there are
remaining concerns when the report comes
out it pretty much is the legislator's
authority to take extra steps to address
those things so from our end there
aren't any preliminary concerns and we
don't influence policy directly so once
you have the report I think you'll have
a better idea of those concerns
Senator Lang and then r gber i I just
want to be careful in our in our um
Trail of the Department of Education
right I mean I think the last sentence
on page seven uh really States what's
going on in in the ability of data and
no amount of laws that we pass can that
inv invalidate another law so it's clear
here it says in addition to the
Department of Education the Attorney
General State's lawyers represent his
interpretation of the state standard
contract which is required to be used by
All State agencies when Contracting
Services does not consider the data
collected or generated by a contractor
to be the property of the state doesn't
give us the right to override that law
if we pass another law right so we'd
have to deal with how the state
contracts are written to deal with
contract law but I want to be clear that
if the agency if the Department of
Education did oversight you have a list
of things on page six and one of which
is identifying recovering and eligible
EFA dispersements topay to students
ensuring phase out grants or paid to
school districts appropriately uh
ensuring that students receive the
correct amount if the agency performed
oversight activity and collected data to
validate that they were doing what they
were supposed to do you all have access
to that data corre so so again I I want
to be careful not portraying Department
of Education it's not cooperating
they're cooperating within the terms of
the law that they're allowed to
cooperate is even identified by the
Attorney General so and I think you'll
be able to do your report based on that
and if we need to adjust the contract to
not to deal with our maybe bad language
in our contract law that we can deal
with
that representative Weber and then
Griffin thank you madam chair I'd like
to ask how many people and how much
effort are we putting in in other words
how many people for how many weeks is
this audit going to take or is it
estimated to take our current team is
myself V skids and one staff auditor so
three of us uh with the our anticipation
is to get it to fiscal spring of
2025 depending we're finishing the audit
plan within the next couple months once
the audit plan is finished we'll have a
better idea of what to expect for a date
for the reports release y representative
weer I think that my question was really
somewhat on the same lines as Senator
Langs of uh just
being sure
that seems to me there two issues here
one is tax dollars and but that's almost
more of a financial audit than a
performance audit and that what you so
what you're going to be looking at if
I'm correct is the actual oversight
provided by the Department of
Education and what procedures and
practice is they are using to comply
with their statutory duty to oversee the
program is that correct y okay thank you
representative
wner thank
you the scholarship organization is a
nonprofit
organization and is there a um fiscal
audit that's available because that
organization as a nonprofit would have
have to be doing regular audits they do
receive financial audits annually and
those are publicly posted and have been
provided okay and those would be
something that you would have access to
and you would look at yes during this
thank
you wait but but I have
okay
so question yes representative Earth uh
thank you madam chair so can you speak
to the other special education audit
that you're doing with the Department of
Education and whether or not you the
audit Auditors have been able to go to
the local school districts kind of
analogous to the CSF Foundation to
determine whether in fact they are
following the law that you are uh
reporting on with regard to the
Department of
Education I can't speak to the special
education audit if you want to ask about
local school districts I believe Jay has
a little more information
on what was decided for going to the
local schools for the special education
audit hello my name is Jay Henry I'm the
performance audit supervisor for the LBA
audit division um with the special ed
audit the big special ed audit um which
um Chris has talked about we're talking
it's going to be big 50 observations it
really that is focused just on the
department and it is not going out to
audit
locals um I I think we've talked about
this before it's um looking at the
program we're sort of better to look at
the state first because they're the ones
setting up the program running the
program and should be managing the
program and if there's if we have issues
with what the state is doing you know um
you can
imagine you know what's happening at the
locals you know they're just reacting to
what the state's doing you know I think
the if if the legislature wanted maybe
after this audit to do more at the local
level that that might be good but I
think there'd be have to be a lot of
changes at the at the at the uh state
level
first followup yes follow so so despite
the fact that the committee when they
originally requested that audit a couple
years ago when I was initially on this
committee specifically requesting that
the local districts be audited because
they were the source of the problem that
the parents were reporting the uh
performance AUD committee chose not to
address that correct well if I remember
the scope statement itself itself uh
that they agreed on this this committee
it was more focused at the the state
level
followup I understand that but the
initial request by the chairman at that
time was broader than the scope
statement that you put forward once that
chairman was no longer the
chairman if I remember that it it sort
of grew that this whole topic it started
out um if I Senator Reagan was the the
chair of a special committee he was also
the chair of this this committee and it
started off with the dispute resolution
was the first thing that
he wanted us to do and we actually did
that audit Paige was the in charge of
that audit and but then as they kept
talking about special
education it grew as far as the the
things they wanted us to look at so
that's how we came and the locals were
discussed but I think it was determined
you know we really got to look at the
the pro the state program itself
first um
Senator Pearl thank you I figured I
might as well chime in everyone
else
so the um the issue here seems to be
that this data that some of the data is
owned by an independent contractor and
not by the state is have have you run
into this issue previously in audits
that you've tried to do and and if so
how have you worked through it
that's more finan some of the financial
audits yeah I
mean I don't recall ever running into um
an issue of this magnitude I mean we do
audit departments that have contracts um
with third parties um but in this
situation because the scholarship
organization essentially
runs um most of the program program um
it it is different and um you know we
have worked
through minor scope limitations before
and we've always been able to come to an
agreement and um obtain the records that
we need to obtain in order to perform
the audit um this is a little different
with the program being established in
the chapter law and uh directing us to
do an audit through the chapter law
versus you you know this committee
directing us to do an audit that is not
established in the chapter law so it is
a little bit different oh yes F so is
there a process where the contractor
themselves can be audited who who would
have the authority to do
that I mean that would be an an
independent uh CPA firm or another um
audit firm we historically have not
audited entities that are not State
agencies thank you
okay except we do have in our statute
there's a weird sort of provision about
being able to uh look at non-state
entities I think there it's like up to F
five over a fiveyear period something
like that with the idea that I think
they knew State funds are going down you
know to the local level um and we we
have looked at other programs like the
the cap programs you know money from the
state will go to these uh cap programs
to do various uh functions for the state
or the or the federal government you
know some of the federal funds go down
and we have been able to audit you know
those programs or receive information
from those programs but it also may be
that their contracts that they have with
the state are stronger or have have
language that allow allow the department
to that departments that have the those
contracts you know access to
data okay thank you so we've all seen
the contract for this program and it
states pretty clearly that all that data
belongs to this
state did the Attorney General oppose
the contract when it came before the
executive
councel not to my knowledge not to our
knowledge no so
they were okay with the fact that well I
think they review like in Medicaid the
state really
owns all the data even though most of
Medicaid is managed by private
entities this is not unique the state
owns the data
contract yeah to me it's an
interpretation of the state contract and
you know
we had our initial view of it we thought
it would look oh boy this they can ask
for all this data if they ask for it we
can look at it we can audit it um they
saw it as know the program set up to be
away from the state run by run by the uh
uh um scholarship program and you know
there was sort of a separation there and
so you know we're we're abiding by sort
of their interpretation of how the the
contract in the law it is and I think
they're still going to get you're still
going to get a good audit out of it it
just won't be as thorough as is where
normally would have yeah Senator
Whitney um thank you madam chair you
know you indicated that you know it's
fairly unusual for this nonprofit
private entity to you know run a state
funded program so you know so deeply so
the depth of how much um you know how
little involvement the doe had has so
essentially that means that the doe has
delegated you know pretty much all of
its authority to the to this nonprofit
organization and and that to me has
resulted in a you know coupled with
their uh as you said the Doe's
interpretation of the contract that has
resulted in a very very troubling lack
of transparency for a significant amount
of State dollars um it does the LBA so
my question is does the LBA have uh the
capacity or would you need something
additional from this committee um
regarding you know sort of uh maybe the
legislature's own interpretation uh of
the contract and what you know the doe
is obligated to request or not
request because I I guess you know my
understanding is that that and I and I
understand why you are you are relying
on the Department of Education
interpretation and but that's the
executive branch we're the legislative
branch and so I'm wondering if you know
there needs to be some additional uh
review of
this yeah I don't I don't think that's
the auditive role I mean that's more of
a legislative function
um again if if
the this
committee wanted a a different
audit you know we're doing a chapter law
audit this committee could come up with
its own audit its own
scope um and if they wanted I guess to
expand what we're doing uh but you still
may run
into problems of
interpretation it gets messy and that's
you know that's why we're sort of we
don't have we just we can do what we can
do but we can't push you know sort of
pass that well to follow up on that
you've said this a would be available in
this
spring um fall goes well budget
season so do you have any sense of
whether it will be available during the
house phase or the Senate phase or not
before the budget is
completed I think we have to Once once
you decide what the scope of the audit
is so whether you approve it as written
or if you you change the scope that
would affect how long it takes and on
but once that's done we we we write our
audit plan and that's really where we
try to get a good estimate of when we
think we're going to get this done if
everything runs smoothly uh so right now
we're just sort of you know we're
estimating spring of 2025 and I don't
you know it's a broad time I know that
because we're not quite sure how long
it's going to take and it's also the
interaction we have with the Department
once we give them observations and
right now we have no clue if it's going
to be one or 20 observations you know we
could and the more observations the more
time it takes for us to write the more
time it takes for them to respond um you
know it's like special ed the reason why
that one's taking so long and that's big
you've told us that's going to be like
this yeah and also we should note that
spring in New Hampshire lasts for about
three days now so I mean you're probably
going to miss the Spring wind know
should should be mud season right that
that would be great okay mud season
Senator I move we approve the scope and
I'd like to speak to my motion is there
a second second by representative Weber
so again I I think until we deal with
the contract law conflict I think this
is the oversight which is a great thing
to look at see they have a respons the
Department of Education has a
responsibility oversight are they
performing their oversight and if they
have performed their oversight Did they
perform it properly I think is the
appropriate thing to do and I think it's
a pretty clean clean vote representative
Weber did you want to speak to your
motion any other
comments ready for a vote the motion is
to approve the scope
statement on uh Doe's oversight of the
EFA program all in favor say I I
any
opposed the motion is adopted
unanimously and thank you very
much
yes the next one let me just announce
now that I am not going to be voting on
this next one and I'll explain why
when LBA talks about what the
issue okay so on to dhs's out ofate
placements this audit was to evaluate
the interplay between the different
agencies and bureaus within the
Department of Health and Human Services
in certifying out of state juvenile
residential
facilities we scheduled an entrance
conference for July
31st uh soon after that during the
planning for the audit we came across a
federal lawsuit against the governor and
DHHS officials over the placement of
foster care children in residential
facilities uh while it appears the
lawsuit doesn't specifically relate to
the two juveniles who were placed in
Tennessee uh there could be some
overlap uh a similar issue happened a
few years ago uh with our performance
audit of uh DHHS is Bureau of elderly
and adult services and that audit is
still pending now uh government auditing
standards require us to evaluate the
effects of legal proceedings on an audit
so after discussing the matter with DHHS
we and DHHS officials believe the audit
could interfere with the lawsuit and
vice versa the lawsuit could interfere
with the
audit because of the lawsuit we
cancelled the entrance conference and
we're suggesting that might be best to
suspend the audit um of out ofate
placements until the legal proceedings
have concluded so uh we're looking for a
vote on this now um unless the committee
would first like to hear from somebody
from the Department of Health and Human
Services um who could provide some more
information on how the issue in the
lawsuit could intersect with the audit
okay and so the rest of my explanation
is that I have a family member who's in
involved with the foster care laws so I
will not be voting on this would the
committee like to hear from
DHHS Madam chair I guess I I'm okay with
the idea this is a past practice of the
AG of us obviously so I don't know that
we need to hear from anybody else I
think we continue to pass
practice Senator Whitney I I would agree
regarding the lawsuit and also uh the
governor just last Friday signed SB b417
which directly relates to the
Department's placement of children um
out of out of state and in state so um
that law needs to be implemented too so
I would agree to the suspension
so move to suspend is there a second
second second hit by Senator Pearl any
further discussion and I will not be
voting all in favor say I I any
opposed and one absten
thank
you okay moving on to the doorway
program we've not started this audit yet
but uh we intend to start in the next
month or so as soon as staff is
available to uh begin that
audit and uh now we can move on to
agenda item number three if that's okay
Madam chair
sure so there are three potential audit
topics on the list one of which is
currently suspended as I mentioned that
was for
beas are there any other topics that
you'd like to add to the
list if so we'd be happy to
discuss any
thoughts didn't we hear some suggestion
and about something out of environmental
services that we decided not to go
forward
with do you remember
that do you remember you do yeah so
again I think this had to do with their
appeals process is what we were talking
about and the idea of again but they've
they're one of the few that actually
have moved the appeals process outside
their agencies to the Attorney General's
office where a lot of agencies do the
appeals process within like save does
their own appeals process within the
department of safety and so um I think
we decided that because that's already
been kind of the model I think maybe
going forward we want to look at um
there was no need to do the audit of
their appeals
process yes
represent the other one that we
suspended last time along with the one
that uh was just described was the
public access to bodies of water and we
we suspended both of those from
consideration they've been sort of
hanging out there for a while and we
simply decided to take them
off so there are a couple other but that
reflected in the minutes yeah there's a
couple of items on this list
DHHS contract Bureau and
BDS um
including possibly reviewing system
redesign and effects on building and
services and or housing practices any
have any thoughts Senator with yeah on
the ladder I think we're still awaiting
a report is that correct on the system
redesign on
BDS I am not sure where that system
redesign stands they started it they
stopped it okay I I don't actually
know where it is but um
there were there was Federal
litigation
again um so maybe that's not a great
topic but how do we feel about contract
management I just I'll just mention I
think contract management uh
representative Wier was one of his
topics and then at the next meeting
Department came in Department officials
and they had actually had developed a
contract management system they there
was a handout and they so you know it
was something that I don't think
repesent wild knew about initially um I
mean it's something that can be audited
but uh I think we were I was surprised
that they had actually come up with the
you know come up with a system which
would probably we'll say Auditors would
like you
know so we don't need that one we don't
need an audit right now but we like to
have some ready to go I mean as you can
tell we've got some audits that are
ongoing we're talking about the spring I
in fact that's probably the earliest
that the next um audit topic after we
start the doorways a it so we don't have
to have one today but we we're always
looking for something to put on the list
so you guys can consider it um I think
we're also coming up to the end of uh
the session or there'll be a new
committee I in
January so whether you want to leave
leave a clean slate or have some
stuff sort of for us to do you know
before you before this committee you
know um dissolves I guess so are you
going to have anything to bring us back
before organization day uh I think the
only one that might be be the doorways
uh scope statement if we can get that
done I'll say December but you know it
all depends on when they start the work
and uh how how big the scope is and
everything representative Weber and then
Senator
Lan that was I think you've just
answered most of my question but um
given that the doorways is already in
the pipeline um it would perhaps I I
don't know if it's at all possible for
for that to
happen before December 5th when
everything changes or December whatever
it is this year it it will start before
like we we're planning on starting it um
but next month my my point is that if we
were to have a vote on a scope statement
it would be helpful to have it in
November so we could vote on it end of
November which is always problematical
anyway because then we have organiz
day and reorganization and you're going
to have to wait for the appointees yeah
and that takes and that takes some time
because um you know leaders from both
parties have to be elected and
then you know it it
just well that may motivate us get it
done that was my precise point if if
there was any way of getting of focusing
on getting that done so that then you
have that on your plate ready uh ready
to work on and then in January you know
we will be reconstituted and and um
ready to start work on whatever comes
next but it sounds to me like you have a
fair amount on your plate
anyway yes but we we'll have some people
freed up to to start right the doorway
one okay Senator L that was a similar
point I was saying and we can use
November to bring in topics at that
point to kind of queue up for the next
committee that comes on board here's the
ideas
so think of so we can so they're not
walking in blind so if we can again use
November like to to her point to
representative point to bring forward
the doorways vote on it and maybe bring
some ideas in for potential topics for
number three there again um we can
recommend for the next committee so I
would like to suggest that we meet the
first week in December because because
it's organization day week and everybody
will be around I mean we had before
organization some people won't be on may
not be on committee anymore well yes but
I mean there's Monday and Tuesday I was
going to say it has to be Monday or
Tuesday because we all become on Persons
at midnight that's true just like
Cinderella right we're going to leave
our glass slippers behind but we know
that people who have been
elected will be around that week so in
the mean time think
of
anything um that your constituent
suggests or that you think needs or
performance on it and um if there's
no
other business we can adjourn the
meeting and it looks like it's 10
2 however it's
10:48 thank you very much thank
you
e for